tierra árida hasta donde se alcanza la
vista y una pequeña aldea perdida en
medio de la nada
estamos en para pool en el norte de
kenia bajo sus chozas de paja locamente
intenta sobrevivir con sus cinco hijos
esta olvidada región del norte no ha
visto una gota de lluvia en los últimos
tres años sólo quedan bayas silvestres
para alimentar a esta tribus de pastores
como ya estamos acostumbrados a nuestra
situación no sabemos cómo cultivar y
todos nuestros animales han muerto por
la sequía estamos esperando a morir de
hambre aquí comer estas bayas es la
única forma que tenemos de sobrevivir
su única fuente de agua es este pozo
insalubre que se está secando día a día
la falta de agua y de pastos ha
provocado la muerte de 15 millones de
reses en kenia ir y pilló la mujer más
anciana de este pueblo ha perdido todas
sus cabras ahora parece resignada
en el pasado y a muchos años entre dos
sequías hoy en día cuando se produce una
sequía puede durar tres años hasta que
todos los pastos se han secado cuando
cuando el ganado muere los humanos
mueren porque nuestras vidas
de los animales para combatir esta
sequía histórica el gobierno keniano
afirma haber gastado más de 75 millones
de dólares pero esta ayuda parece
insuficiente en las regiones desérticas
del norte casi un millón de niños
menores de 5 años sufren actualmente de
desnutrición aguda